[Music]
hello I'm gonna stab great guy remember
it so you don't have to a wonder
brothers anime bill that isn't the Iron
Giant solo
[Music]
I honestly think from day one I've been
getting requests to review this movie
when we don't know anyone that sees the
1994 adaptation Wan Lake as the worst
thing ever it does carry this
awkwardness that just enough people saw
to make for more direct-to-dvd awkward
missis's it also helps that the movie at
the time was very well advertised every
other kids show had a commercial for
this playing in between but also keep in
mind that at the time the only animation
studio making any kind of profit back
then was Disney and just the same way
Disney re-released the Little Mermaid
for a limited time when Anastasia posed
a threat guess what movie only five
months after its premiere they decided
to re-release on the exact same day no I
use go seek movie Disney's a mermaid at
the time what lousy luck what are the
chances we just happen to re-release
this film on the exact same weekend
accompanies a monster but after it once
a video kids were still kind of curious
whether or not there was anything worth
watching in it the answer well let's
take a look for ourselves this is the
law requested Swan Princess
the film opens up wants a pond every
fairy tale backwash has an old King
awaits the birth of his first child he
was growing old and had no child to
inherit the throne then happily a
daughter was born and she was given the
name
odet here's to the assumption that her
mother diamond burger many come from
across the land to visit the newborn
three-year-old and the king forms a plan
with a queen from another kingdom to
play matchmaker with their kids but an
evil sorcerer named Rothbart whose name
is so strange I need more time to think
about proper joke for it
apparently has other plans where he was
preparing to take Williams Kingdom by
means of the forbidden arts through the
evil leprechaun magic of pink hearts
yellow moons green clovers and blue
diamonds they're magically diabolical so
his scheme is stopped our villain played
by the late Jack Palance where's his
life to get revenge someday I'll get my
power back and what I do everything my
number-one guy so y'all know dead and a
young Derek are forced to hang out with
each other but as is typical of any 90s
romance they of course have to hate each
other throughout the majority of the
process now to its credit the fact that
they're bitter kids it does make this
scene work a little better and yeah it's
actually kind of a cute number that is
when they're not obviously ripping off
other Disney trademarks I think you
really sort of like curves up Beauty and
the Beast
good ochio
sois Beasley Sleeping Beauty I can't
believe you're ripping off Sleeping
Beauty have you no shame but then quite
literally out of nowhere they suddenly
love each other again I guess like most
nineties romances she started and
somehow suddenly became us wahh
oh no isn't that a charming lesson years
of hate and abuse are fine in a
relationship as long as your sexual
urges deem your partner a sweet piece of
ass hey your work to make Ryan built and
she turned out just fine
don't do what they do in meg Ryan films
arrange the marriage arrange the
marriage
they've been arranging it practically
since you were a sperm what you're all I
ever wanted you're beautiful but what
else what else what else is there
wait wait I know this one um I can put
my dick in you uh you're sizzling
arm-candy
uh you're a means to my incredibly
shallow end we tried you betta no one
can say we didn't try yes the parents
should be very upset that a couple who
hated each other yet we're forced to be
together still end up hating each other
clearly this is all the children's fault
you must see something other than beauty
of course I do Rogers she's like you
know how about and then I mean right
look she makes my hose jump okay it's
the Middle Ages love is like an
appetizer it's good to start off with
but not essential but little do they
know that
Rothbart god it's like the sound you
make when you hiccup and belch wobbler
turns into an evil animal and takes
Odette away Derek arrives on the scene
we're not Disney no matter how hard we
try to make it look will never be Disney
where is Odette
[Music]
well I know she's so dead but that
doesn't answer my question
[Music]
Oh forever miss your beauty and nothing
else
so we discover that the people Rothbart
sounds like a gay porno with the leasing
or event halen has kidnapped Odette and
has whisked her away to the horrible
devastating previous evil lair banished
make and buy why the fuck does he want
the keys land he's living in a resort by
Thomas Kincade don't check my little
spell make you sad or dead so he turns
her into a swan but apparently the
moonlight only on delay can change her
back to normal he also reveals that the
confession of one's true love is the
only thing that'll stop the
transformation but I really want is your
father you have enough power
once you steal something you spend your
whole life fighting will rule your
father's kingdom together where are you
going soon this moonlight leaves the
lake you turn back into wow I mean wow
you've been waiting over what ten years
to put this plane together and that's
that's your big magnum opus that you
finally scrounged up come in here come
in here I'm sorry it's just I need help
to get this out as quickly as possible
because there are just too damn maid to
go through so without further ado
everything wrong with this plan in under
40 seconds yeah if she did agree what's
to stop her from changing her mind after
the spell is broken
if object is a swan what's to stop her
from flying away and communicating with
someone by writing the same if he wants
to marry her legally why does he just
hypnotized her to say yes the only thing
to break the spell is the person
confessing their love why seems
counterproductive to the plan
what's the stopper in human form from
sneaking up behind him and knocking the
fuck around is there really no law to
marrying banish people can't seems like
a no-brainer you just
in the day doing nothing why does he do
something
couldn't he threaten someone she loves
to force her to marry him she doesn't
really have an acceptance if he can
change anyone to anything wait doesn't
he change anyone to anything he can make
himself look like the king he can make
someone else look like Odette but
there's a million other ways around this
oh that's it but thank you guys so much
now back to the closet until I need you
again no but it smells like dead armpit
in there yeah
hey usually next time I have a salmon
axe joke never makes enough of those
so Derek test his skills by having an
arrow shoot at him one can only hope
this leads to a st. Sebastian homage you
even know who that is do you don't go to
Google your soul knows the truth
[Music]
uh yeah can we get the judges take on
that that's what I thought even for a
fancy aimed at two-year-olds that's
pretty fucking stupid but he also
practices his hunting skills on some of
his servants that's that lady it's not
as violent as you would think five
episodes of Animaniacs were good enough
to bring you this now we'll never see
the episode where pinky in the break
this really warranting of a song do
these characters we've never seen before
and won't see again demand a musical
interpretation of their emotional
struggle well
something you'll discover is remember
how even though it was kind of corny
that child characters were actually
pretty distinct memorable and even
surprisingly enjoyable
well fellas before they remembered oh
yeah we're diet Disney anything that was
different and unique has to be tossed
out for one calorie of the enjoyment
because of this Oh dad and Derek have
little to no personality from this point
on yeah see how expressive they are see
how funny they are see how different
from every other animated film out at
the time they seem to be Chuck and now
watching our characters it's like seeing
an unsalted cracker proposed to a sheet
of sandpaper nothing stands out about
them at all and that somehow is supposed
to make you care about so to make up for
how incredibly boring they are they give
all the colorful songs to hastily rush
comic relief that serve little to no
purpose in the story like the coach
servants aw
the woman we know aren't going to marry
Derick so there's no purpose to them at
all saw and of course a song so
desperate to be popular they named it
after a dying 90s t-shirt franchise not
that I'm complaining
keep it alive people keep it alive that
last song by the way is sent by Diet
Disney comic relief as well one is a
fraud voiced by John Cleese doing a
god-awful lumière impression no no I
think his other French take better in
your direction your mother was a hamster
and your father now go away or I shall
taunt you a second time and an upbeat
old turtle voice by just give her these
flowers these are pretty oh god shit are
you serious Stephen right friends call
me speed ready for action sir okay you
don't mess as they put it Brit as a
French man I'm not against this guy's an
actor at all far from it I'm sure he can
be great but you have to put up fitting
voice with a fitting character the
turtle is usually smiling all he's
getting involved and feels a constant
need to help people would you choose
this guy for that you said if you could
know how and when you were gonna die
would you want to know I said no she
said to get it done he's the only actor
who can completely not try for a role
and you would never know the difference
unless your character is called the
prissy duck or suicidal salamander it's
not gonna work I can only kiss the man I
love and then he must make a vow to the
world
wow that's a pretty egotistical spell
you got there
I don't know how to Hollywood couples
try that it doesn't usually turn out
very good for them
meant to be
but hey that would be indicating that
this movie knows nothing about real love
and hell we all know that's not true
take this scene where are a couple
things about how much they love one
another even though they let them bad
turns called off a wedding 90% of what
we saw up and convinces us why they
shouldn't be together and absolutely
nothing about them has changed at all um
true yep there's nothing in this movie
outside of one log where they ever share
any chemistry
remember when Odette once Derek to say
something else he likes about her aside
from her beauty its beauty all that
matters to you what else is there no the
more think about I'm siding with him
what else is there nothing stands out
about you two that makes you interesting
at all if this movie can't explain what
else about them is supposed to be unique
why should the characters Disney develop
more on-screen charisma with characters
that you only knew for a few days you
guys had a fucking childhood to develop
their romance and you still ended up
watching it how is that possible
[Music]
so Derek is bound to figure out what the
Kings last words meant by the parade
animal it's not what it seems an animal
that can change its shape a harmless
creature approaches then suddenly it's
denied me I mean it could be anything
anything okay I guess that's a clue but
what are you gonna do about it
oh you know the great animal when you
see it oh no that's right they go around
to random animals any fucking random
animals and just start shooting at them
heck he even goes after her dead trying
to avenge or get a swan course this one
[Music]
what the fuck is wrong with these people
this is both stupid and insane even the
McCarthy trials weren't quite this
ludicrous mr. rooster you have a great
animal um no yes you are
Miss Kitty are you the great animal yes
nice try mr. mole are you the great
animal I'm mo always great wrong answer
mister where am i you the great animal
well my friends always call me great
whatever take this huh it'll take more
than a doll to do it I mean do they have
any brain cells in them any logical
thinking I mean it makes no fucking
sense anyone could be the great animal I
could be the great animal we gotta take
a break we'll be right back
you
so that tries to outrun Derek while her
cuddly friends try to help her out the
always popular smoke from arrow makes
beard gag classic but she leads him into
the pond where she shows her true colors
[Music]
can't stay he'll never let you out of my
sight again you're just so beautiful and
nothing else
it must be some way to break the spell
you must make a vow of everlasting love
you must prove it to the world tomorrow
night before the whole world I will make
a vow of everlasting love and by the
whole world I mean the small number of
people I can crowd into one room inside
my castle I hope the spell it's not a
number cruncher
so we take some debt with her as a swan
as he's promised never to lose her again
or he just leaves her in the hands of a
psychotic monster as most loved ones -
but it turns out our villain has heard
the whole thing oh I would make a foul
thought you could fool why can't you
just get Stockholm Syndrome like
everyone else I brought here
I had the turtle ready to marry me in a
week so he develops a new plan now he's
gonna change his helper it to Odette and
have her go in her place which was what
plan number five we discussed earlier
and he announces this of course in saw
up to
[Music]
I intend to eat my god there's nothing
more terrifying than a tap-dancing
sorcerer who plans on eating people's
lunches this diabolical betty has
entered the realms of rude
[Music]
really you think this song is good
enough to warrant a one more time I know
you gotta fill up that 90 minutes
somehow but could you put that extra
effort into hiding the obvious frame
cell at the edge of the screen no I mean
the magical bar hollowness that seems to
make an appearance quite a bit in this
movie actually you know this feels empty
enough without uncompleted backgrounds
so well the Queen prepares the ball to
match up Derek with another princess
Derek prepares to use the ball as a
chance to confess his love but
everything apparently needs to be quite
specific
I don't want red roses I want white like
a swamp would you feed this to a swan
tonight the music must be played soft
and graceful like a swan
these bowls that they must be made
bigger so people can dip their heads in
them while eating like a swan these for
that they must be prepared for people
that shit all over them whenever they
please like a swan
these clothes that we must find
something more fitting like now that's
just a bit so long debt is locked away
by Rothbart sounds like an IRA plan
involving the Simpsons while an impostor
goes in her place I was so worried I
almost thought nothing could keep me
away
Little Mermaid me what original fucked
our masters who could come up with an
original idea of everybody on the earth
was dead and there was nobody around to
steal ideas around for the rest of your
days no cheese no huh I don't know wait
a minute why don't they recognize her is
Odette really so bland that watching her
girl up throughout her entire childhood
honestly left no impact on them
whatsoever
she really is beautiful and nothing else
so what does friends help her escape by
fighting the ripped off designs from all
dogs go to heaven
Beatrice TV but arrives at the castle
just a moment too late Oh No
instead of confessing his love to Odette
he confessed his love to old dad wait
this makes no sense he still said Odette
but nothing in this Belle said she had
to be in the same room it's not like he
said I confessed my love to this person
on my left he clearly said Odette you
know this is really why spells need to
be looked over by lawyers first
I greet you with she don't like me wait
why will Odette die okay even she did
doesn't he still need to marry her was
that the whole idea behind the plan to
begin with how is he gonna rule the land
if he still has no position look I know
I shouldn't have picked in a fairy tale
cuz that's a fairy tale that's just
stupid but half the dialogue in this is
about how the ownership of this kingdom
works he was sad before he had no child
to inherit the throne will join our
lands if this arrangement will rule your
father's kingdom together legally I'm
only putting so much damn focus on
because they put so much damn focus on
it fuck these guys the politics of Game
of Thrones is easier to follow than this
[Music]
I can't lose your beauty and nothing
else for her
do you hear oh I make my Napoleon
Dynamite face in your honor and yet
don't let her die if you defeat
[Music]
[Applause]
animal my god the king was right the
great animal wasn't at all what it
seemed it was an evil creature of
Darkness who consumed anything that was
in its way
actually that is exactly what it would
seem you were chasing a mouse a fucking
mouse cars overused not specifically
made dying words good lord I'm shocked
at all my years of shooting people and
Bunny outfits has in no way prepared me
for this
but diet Lefou comes in they pull that
arrow bullshit again and the entire
climax is only under two minutes law hey
I guess I shouldn't be complaining it is
mercifully short but man I'm fuckin I'm
not complaining Swiss police shorten
that of course somehow breaks the spell
to get married the next day because
obviously they've learned so much more
about each other and the future sequels
fly overhead the prince what's the point
an Air Force and it's more just to get
you birds in shape no which one of you
will be hand drawn straight to DVD which
one of you will be computer-generated
straight to DVD I'm
[Music]
I've got some schmoozing to do
alright let's just decree that somehow
The Princess and the Frog probably
ripped this off and we can all go back
to making original content again okay
okay because there's not much more than
I it Disney I can take this film feels
like the movie that in Shanta was
satirizing in the first third it doesn't
feel like someone wanted to tell a story
out of passion it feels like it was told
because someone else was making money
with this other formula and now they're
gonna try that formula the leads are a
bore the comedies week the animation is
much better at being wild and energized
rather than soothing and romantic but
even then a lot of the timing and
characters are so poorly executed that
even that doesn't hold much water
the only thing close to enjoyable is
that opening number heck if the movie
was just about these kids growing up I
think we might have had a stronger movie
but as is it's phoned in unimaginative
and just a dull waste I can tell you
right now that's the last time I ever
subject myself to die at Disney I'm done
astound your credit guy remember it so
you don't have to see hey guys how'd you
get out of the closet oh we've had a way
out for a while we've just been making
you think we're always stuck in later
yes and we've been using our time
growing bitter against you and working
out a way to seek our revenge yeah
that's correct
you know I got to tell you I am so sick
of these diet Disney spin-offs I'm so in
the mood for something new well why not
try this it's Diet DreamWorks I don't
care what's in it
Oh everything from the nut job hood weed
and all the real and Ice Age CDs that's
twice now I've been so mean to blue sky
studios I should probably stop that they
were made something good well if you
need more variety you can always try a
diet Pixar oh what's that one was a very
simple recipe it's all the Pixar sequels
excluding Toy Story of course of course
I mean every diet product gets like
enhanced out of the substance every once
in a while oh and here's what you can
use in your next review so zero oh hey I
love dr. Seuss no no critic this
zero it doesn't have any of the dr.
Seuss genius in it at all
Wow that would be great for a review but
uh what's in it why is it all orange
Oh
[Music]
would you feed this to a swamp